Chris Brown and Rihanna just when you
thought you've heard it all like me I
felt my [ __ ] monster welcome back to
the daily Denny Chris Brown in his own
words giving a graphic recount of the
night he hit Rihanna it's some heavy
stuff and Chris spares no details about
his relationship with RiRi it's all for
his new documentary Chris Brown welcome
to my life
Chris says the two were never the same
after he admitted to sleeping with
another woman early on in their
relationship
and that things only got worse when they
apparently ran into said woman at the
clive gave his party the night before
the 2009 Grammy like I remember she
tried to kick me he's like just heard
this being said but then already hit it
I got hung up with the clothes was like
I'm punched and it uh busted her lip and
when I saw it I was in shock under
hailing I hit her like I looked back
into the picture and I'm just like no
room right That's not me
oh that's not that's not me I hate it to
this day you know there's a there's no
harm is room Chris was ultimately
charged with felony assault for
attacking Rihanna he pleaded guilty but
what do you guys make of Chris being so
candid I mean it's a pretty gnarly
detail there and I wasn't even all of it
do you guys think it was the right move
let us know in the comment section
all right but switching gears now to the
new season of Project Runway which
premieres tonight on lifetime now if you
could believe it it is the 16th season
of the show and boy are they changing
things up on that runway this season
judge and host Heidi Klum gave me the
scoop on the new switch up
that didn't exactly throw the designers
we're so excited for the new season of
Project Runway what is very exciting
about this year we have models of all
sizes which I believe we should have
done already years and years and years
ago so I'm happy though that now this
season we're starting
these girls they have curves and butts
and hips and all kinds of asbestos what
were the designers reactions knowing
that they would have to design for women
who maybe don't fit the typical you know
model standing kind of went like this
you know some of them a lot of them
actually weren't too happy about it Ruth
no but you know this is the real world
not everyone is you know a runway figure
what the runway figure used to be you
know you have to dress real people and
when people come in different sizes
short tall global actua skinny you know
there's many of us and so a real
designer needs to know how to do that so
get with it on the trail also teased a
lot of drama there's a contestant walks
off the runway for the way that it was
done I do not agree with Michael wire
you want to have to say this has ever
happened in this week's show I came to
the play fair and there's no fairness in
this case what happened what she's about
that moment I mean you have to watch and
see this I have never had this happen
before you know especially when I'm like
hey guys what's going on and they don't
listen to me either they just walk away
I'm like wait a minute I run this show
oh my what is going on here you guys all
look so comfortable in my studio we're
in for an exciting season on a good
season full of drama and as Kim Gunn
would say make it work designers and as
Tyra would say but make it fashion yes I
realized that it's two different shows
but same difference and finally how is
this war a sweet gesture a denver
company displayed messages of support to
Taylor Swift during her groping trial
which was going on in the courthouse
across the street now throughout the
week long court battle office workers
decorated the windows of their building
with some of Taylor's song titles and
lyrics like people throw rocks at things
that shine and haters gonna hate
well the messages did not go unnoticed
by the pop star in fact Taylor sent
flowers to the employees at craft C and
thank them for quote brightening my day
for every day I was in Denver the
company tweeted a photo with the
assortments writing Thank You Taylor
Swift we're so happy our messages
brighten your day
as much as your flowers brightened ours
meanwhile Taylor appears to be a woman
of her word
because after saying she wanted to help
survivors of sexual assault following
her victory in court earlier this week
she made a donation to actress Mariska
Hargitay joyful heart foundation Taylor
is both of course a fan and friend
Anushka who starred in Taylor's bad
blood video Taylor even named her cat
Olivia after mariscos law-and-order
character now regarding the amount of
Taylor's donation the foundation CEO
said it was an extremely generous
financial investment in the move to end
sexual violence
Marishka also said that she hopes
Taylor's very public experience helps
empower other victims to speak up and
take action and you know what cheers to
that well guys it is almost Friday and
tomorrow we are doing a deep dive into
Justin Bieber's new song is it about ex
Selena Gomez so hit subscribe and then
like comment and share this video and
thank you guys for watching them see you
guys tomorrow
which way here I go I'm going this way